[Musique]
durant trois jours le 83e salon du
fait-main s'est déroulée à la halle des
manifestations du port un salon qui
rassemble plus de 150 exposants de toute
l'île des artisans qui sous forme
d'exposition vente proposent des
produits locaux et artisanaux de qualité
l'artisanat réunionnais avec l'appui
notamment de notre collectivité
représente la ferveur que nous avons au
conseil départemental d'accompagner les
talents réunionnais notre fée main notre
savoir faire pour que demain nos notre
artisanat notre si belle artisanale
variés passe les limites et les
frontières de notre île et qu'il rayonne
à l'international pourquoi pas
le conseil départemental étaient
présents sur ce salon avec un stand
réservé à sa filière bois de goyavier un
produit pays largement plébiscité par
les réunionnais compte tenu de la
qualité du travail et des réalisations
lydéric d'autres matériaux naturels plus
connus
il ya cinq ans on a développé à
l'interné une
filière en proposant
divers produits et variées
pour nos besoins
des services et montrer surtout qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire avec
ce ou ces matériaux locaux
aujourd'hui on présente quand même
l'activité sur le secteur marchand
le public a pu profiter d'un atelier
d'initiation à la fabrication d'objets
mais aussi de faire l'acquisition de
mobilier ou d'articles de décoration
alors le produit standard telles que
l'époque dans son les porte manteaux
les ustensiles de la cuisine de la salle
de bains ou voilà tout ça autour de ça à
partir du bois de goyavier et autres
matériaux locaux et
une otite gamme
coin salon petit coin salon
un succès qui ne faiblit pas durant
trois jours l'enceinte portoise a
accueilli de nombreux visiteurs pour
cette 83ème édition du salon du fait
main
[Musique]